يبدو أنه كل 24 شهرًا تقريبًا
توجد مدينة صغيرة مختلفة تم
تجاهلها إلى الأبد ، وهي
تنمو تنمو تنمو تنمو تنمو
عادةً مدفوعًا
بالثروة الاقتصادية ، أعني أن ابتكار الطعام في
جميع أنحاء البلاد في الوقت الحالي كان
عميقاً ومثيراً للاهتمام مثل  حتى
قبل عشرين عامًا كنت معتادًا على الذهاب إلى
شيكاغو لوس أنجلوس سان فرانسيسكو ونيويورك
لتناول الطعام الآن يمكنك الذهاب وتناول طعامًا رائعًا
ومينيابوليس مثل
الطعام المذهل ولكنني قمت للتو برحلتي الأولى إلى
مينيابوليس وقد وقعت
في حبها تمامًا  أعتقد أنها واحدة من
تلك المدن الفريدة من نوعها ،
فهناك الكثير من الفخر من الناس
الذين يعيشون هناك وهذا يشعرني جيدًا
أنني أتواصل مع أنني وجدت
برمنغهام مدينة مثيرة للغاية لأتناولها في
طريقي ومن كان سيحصل عليها
اعتقدت أن برمنغهام هي
كتلة صلبة من الذهب في نهر من الطين ، لدينا الآن
مطاعم في أماكن لن
تفكر فيها أبدًا في وجود مطعم
برمنغهام هي واحدة من مينيابوليس  هو شيء آخر
أعتقد أن بوفالو لديه بعض الطعام الرائع ، وبعض
الأنواع المفضلة لدي من مدن الطعام السرية
هذه الأيام هي طعام دنفر المذهل الذي
شاهده الكثير من الطهاة المبتكرين الشباب
وكل ما سمعت عنه هو ناشفيل
وهي تزدهر إنها مدينة طعام مزدهرة
أنا  سوف نقول لـ Louisville من أجل
الفوز لقد أتت فيلادلفيا حتى الآن في
العقد الماضي أو هكذا هي مرتع للطعام الجيد في
الوقت الحالي ، لقد أعدنا تسكين
المناطق التي ذهب الجميع إلى المدن
الكبرى والآن عادوا إلى حيث
هم  فيما يتعلق بالمكان الذي ينتمون إليه ويقومون
بالفعل ببناء هذه الأماكن الواقعية ،
فهم يستعرضون حقيقة
ما هو الطعام الأمريكي حقًا
[موسيقى]